director adam wingard's titanic
blockbuster godzilla vs kong
absolutely delivers on the heavyweight
brawl promised in the title
but it's very light on logic perplexed
by the plot of godzilla vs kong
here are the most confusing moments
explained
in godzilla vs kong major concepts get
brief bits of exposition hollow earth
for example
is a major plot point but most of its
history is only laid out during the
opening credits
as the credits state in 1926 an
american admiral led an expedition to
the north pole
although it's not clear if he found
hollow earth this admiral
is very clearly supposed to be richard e
bird a real life figure who's inexorably
linked to the idea of hollow earth
in 1926 bird voyaged to the north pole
although whether he actually succeeded
is a matter of debate
byrd has since become a pivotal figure
in the real life
hollow earth conspiracy theory yeah
that's a thing
and godzilla vs kong has embraced that
making him one of the first
hollow earth pioneers at least in the
monster verse
even if you accept the idea that there
are tunnels
burrowing through earth hiding tropical
landscapes and
long-lost civilizations godzilla vs
kong's hollow earth is a little
confusing
the gravity paradox allowing kong to
jump mario galaxy style from one
landmass to another
and making entry to hollow earth so
dangerous
doesn't really make sense also it's
awfully bright down there
given that the sun is on the other side
of the earth's surface
godzilla vs kong never explicitly
explains how
all of this works but it's easy to come
up with some suitable theories
after all the concept of hollow earth
has been a mainstay in mythology
folklore and kooky pseudoscience for
centuries
jules verne's 1864 novel journey to the
center of the earth
while explicitly fiction uses
electromagnetic phenomena
a luminous cloud of gas and glowing
lichen to explain why there's light
inside
in 1913 canadian marshall gardner
published his admittedly non-scientific
treatise
a journey to the earth's interior which
argued that there could be a second
smaller sun inside the earth which is a
possible explanation for the source of
hollow earth's light
and its wonky physics in the monster
verse of course in this case the
simplest explanation may be the best
some fans think that the earth's core
provides both gravity
and light to hollow earth hey as far as
pseudoscience goes
it works kind of rensarazawa
apex cybernetics cto and mechagodzilla's
ill-fated pilot
gets a big introduction in godzilla vs
kong
but doesn't really seem like much more
than a hired goon in the end
why give such a minor character so much
focus
there's actually a very good reason you
wouldn't catch this unless you're all
caught up on your monster verse lore
but as ren's last name implies he's the
son of monarch scientist
ishiro ishiro first appeared in 2014's
godzilla
where he served as an advocate for the
big lizard and returned for 2019's
godzilla king of the monsters
in which his bond with the titan grew
even closer
correctly surmising that godzilla was
nature's defense against both the titans
and environmental ruin sirozawa
sacrificed his life to detonate the
nuclear bomb
that nursed and injured godzilla back to
health giving the monster the strength
he needed to stop ghidorah
and his reign of terror in godzilla vs
kong
kong looks very different from when we
last saw him in kong
skull island basically he's bigger a
whole lot bigger
in skull island which takes place in
1973
the ape is a mere 104 feet tall by 2024
when godzilla vs kong takes place he's
grown to 337 feet
according to an official poster for the
movie there's an obvious reason for the
size change
in order to make kong a credible threat
to godzilla who stands at a
whopping 393 feet kong needs to be in at
least the same weight class
however there is an in-universe reason
as to why kong grew over 300 bigger too
you don't want to wake up the big one
how big is it it's bigger it wiped out
his whole family
kong's the last of his kind but he's
still growing by the time
godzilla vs kong rolls around he's gone
through a major growth spurt
and as far as we know we'll keep getting
larger
either way this is a major upgrade for
kong who was only 18 feet tall during
the jungle scenes in his 1933 debut
feature
and 24 feet in the sequences set in new
york city that makes sense though
in the 1933 movie kong has to climb the
empire state building
which stands at 1 250 feet and
is taken out by a handful of biplanes in
godzilla vs kong
he's knocking over entire skyscrapers
without a second thought
so yeah it's a big difference if you
thought that
hey maybe building a robotic titan out
of one of the most dangerous kaiju
ever was a bad idea and guess what you
were right
as godzilla vs kong reveals
mechagodzilla was constructed out of two
skulls
harvested from godzilla king of the
monster's main villain
the three-headed monster known as both
monster zero and ghidorah
one skull is inside the robot the other
houses the piloting interface that
renzirizawa
uses to control mechagodzilla and
communicates with a mechanical titan
using ghidorah's innate psychic
abilities at least that's the plan
when apex injects mechagodzilla with the
hollow earth power source
rin loses control of the beast the movie
doesn't make this entirely clear
so just in case you were wondering this
isn't just mechagodzilla going rogue
in this moment idora's consciousness
actually takes over mechagodzilla's
mechanical body
bringing him back to life this makes the
following godzilla vs mechagodzilla
fight
much more personal this is a grudge
match both monsters have personal stakes
teenage monster hunter madison
conspiracy theorist bernie
and madison's buddy josh go on a pretty
circuitous journey while uncovering
apex's plans for mechagodzilla
first bernie downloads classified
information from an apex computer
learning that the company is making many
mysterious shipments to hong kong
next he sneaks into a restricted area in
apex's pensacola laboratory
catching a glimpse of an ominous device
during the middle of godzilla's attack
later bernie takes madison and josh to
see the machine
only to discover it's missing from there
the trio get caught in one of the hong
kong-bound crates
there they learned that the mystery
cargo consists of skull crawler eggs
which are usually only found on skull
island
once they're in hong kong the unlikely
investigators see a live
skull crawler and watch horrified as
mechagodzilla utterly destroys it
finally revealing apex's master plan
that's a very roundabout way to reveal
mechagodzilla
and you'd be forgiven for losing some of
the plot along the way
for example what is the thing that
bernie sees during godzilla's initial
onslaught
while some fans seem to think that it's
a variation on the orca device
used to lure titans in godzilla king of
the monsters
and bernie seems to forget about it
entirely once mechagodzilla is revealed
it looks like it's one of
mechagodzilla's glowing red eyes
look at the close-up on the eye when
mechagodzilla wakes up it's clearly the
same thing
godzilla relies on more than just brute
strength
in addition to his size he has a number
of powers
including his iconic atomic breath that
he uses to decimate his foes
and so in order to give kong a fighting
chance godzilla vs kong
had to even the odds by giving the giant
primate an axe
which comes with some special abilities
of its own not only is the axe key to
unlocking hollow earth's ultra potent
power source
but it can absorb godzilla's atomic
breath and dish it back to him
however godzilla vs kong only hints at
where the axe came from
and doesn't spend much time explaining
how it works
for that you need to turn to a collider
interview with godzilla vs kong writer
and key monsterverse contributor max
borenstein
bornstein told the outlet to me it's
like godzilla's scales have this
conductive
radioactive quality and the primate
kongs had a kind of evolved civilization
of sorts
as primates might and simple tools and
had used the spine of a godzilla
creature to create it
so yeah the ax's blade's resemblance to
godzilla's back spikes
isn't an accident the axe is literally
made
out of the body of godzilla's ancestor
other than that
bornstein isn't saying much else about
the axis history
although there's clearly more there to
explore director adam wingard told
collider
it's something that we just kind of
tease at in the movie and hopefully we
can explore in later films
one of the coolest moments in godzilla
vs kong occurs when godzilla
suddenly alarmed by kong's activation of
the hollow earth energy source
fires up his atomic breath and blows a
hole to the center of the earth
opening a new passage from hollow earth
to the surface
it's also unfortunately one of the most
confusing moments
how does godzilla know what kong is up
to for one and why doesn't the gravity
barrier that made travel between the two
realms so difficult seem to apply here
the answer to that first question is
implied although not outright stated
in the previous monsterverse films the
first monsterverse film
2014's godzilla establishes that titans
like godzilla are drawn to immense power
sources
especially nuclear ones when kong powers
up the hollow earth throne room
it seems likely that godzilla simply
detected the energy surge
particularly if his genetic memory
something we know the titans have
kicked at after all they've probably
encountered the energy before
as for the gravity barrier well there
are a few possible explanations
maybe godzilla's atomic breath disrupted
the barrier that separates hollow earth
from our world
maybe the veil only applies to the
hollow earth tunnel in antarctica
in godzilla king of the monsters for
example monarch's submarine
has a much easier time reaching
godzilla's hollow earth hideout
most likely however is that the sequence
is just awkwardly cut
we see kong and the hollow earth
expeditions heave head into the tunnel
but we don't see most of their time
passing through besides when he emerges
nathan yells we're about to breach the
veil
so it seems like it still happens it's
just not as visually spectacular as
before
by that point in the story there's
plenty else to look at after all
godzilla vs kong director adam wingard
promised that the titular brawl would
have a definitive winner
and he didn't lie however some viewers
seem to think that the movie
ended in a draw it's easy to see how
they'd reach that conclusion
like the best superhero team ups kong
and godzilla
ultimately put aside their differences
and work together to take out the bad
guy
mechagodzilla by the time the credits
roll the two titans have struck up a
begrudging truce
and gone their separate ways now
godzilla rules over the surface
while hollow earth is kong's domain
before they make an
uneasy piece however the epic clash has
a clear winner
godzilla there's no doubt about it kong
and godzilla battled two times in the
movie
once while kong is in route to
antarctica and again
in hong kong the first fight isn't even
close
the fight begins with kong drugged and
shackled and takes place in the ocean
godzilla's home turf kong doesn't stand
a chance
the second fight is more even thanks to
the neutral ground and kong's axe but
godzilla still has the upper hand
yes after absorbing godzilla's atomic
breath with his axe and delivering a
near knockout blow
nathan says looks like round two goes to
car but just a few minutes later
godzilla is back on his feet
and kong gets beaten so hard that his
heart begins to stop
and the humans have to jump start the
big guy to keep him from dying
face it kong might be cinematic royalty
but when it comes down to it
godzilla is the true king of the
monsters
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
godzilla vs kong are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one